hey guys it's max with max tech today we
are gonna be taking a look at the new
Galaxy s5 II this is a new tablet from
Samsung and we're gonna be comparing it
directly against Apple's brand new iPad
air or if you want to call it the iPad
air 3 both of these tablets have their
strengths and weaknesses so we're gonna
look at a wide variety of things
starting off with the display quality
the quality of actual devices cameras
speakers performance all of that stuff
and more so make sure you guys stick
around now let's start out with the
price the s5 e comes in a $400 compared
to 500 for the iPad air 3 both at 64
gigabytes of memory for 80 bucks more
you can jump up to 128 gig with the s5
II and with the iPad you have to go up
to 256 which cost you an extra $150 now
the Samsung does have a strengths and
that is an SD card slot so for just
about 40 bucks more you can add an
additional 256 gigs of storage that's
fairly fast and I'll go all the way up
to 512 so that does save you some money
let's go and get this thing out of the
box and G's first impressions I haven't
held this thing yet it feels really
lightweight let me let me do this again
I've read the specs and it didn't seem
like that big of a difference but wow
that just jumped out at me as soon as
they took it out geez I I'm shocked by
how much of a weight difference there is
let's take a quick look at the
accessories we have a charger looks like
the same one with the Galaxy phones it's
15 watts compared to 12 watts with the
iPad a little dongle that must mean that
we have no headphone jack no headphone
jack but at least they include this in
the box you may have noticed I have
something else over here and this is
Samsung's a book cover keyboards $129
made specifically for the s5e
for the iPad air it uses same keyboard
as the iPad pro the previous generation
that comes in a hundred and $59 now as
far as the actual build quality this
thing feels surprisingly good I'm fairly
impressed with the build quality a
little smart connector doesn't feel as
flush as what Apple offers and even
though these are both 10 and 1/2 inch
displays as you can tell the Samsung has
thinner bezels so it's both not as tall
shorter and not as wide as the
looking at the back of the devices you
may be able to tell that the iPad air
does not have a camera bomb but not is
nice if you want to set it down on the
surface but as you'll see later there
may be some downsides to that the iPad
does have a headphone jack which is nice
that it's still there but we are missing
extra speakers this scanner seems like
the same one as on the s10 II which I
loved it was super fast while the s5 II
downloads a bunch of apps and updates
like Android devices always do let's
compare the displays so this is a 16 by
10 display aspect ratio it's interesting
that they chose that instead of 16 by 9
like Android tablets used to do whereas
our iPad is 4 by 3 and I'm gonna raise
the brightness here and I want to
compare the maximum brightness that it
allows us to have the iPad does seem to
be a little bit brighter on the whites
if I look right from the top the iPad
looks brighter at this point this much
of an angle
the Samsung looks brighter and then
looking from about 45 degree angle the
Samsung looks much brighter so it's
interesting we don't have much brighten
to shift on the Samsung at all let's
take a closer look at the display
quality opened up a really nice YouTube
video this is 60 frames per second it
goes I think 4k or even higher than that
it's also HDR and the first thing that I
notice is the how much bigger the images
on the s5e so if I set this side-by-side
here the image is wider than the image
on the iPad pro the actual video size on
top of that looking this way it's
actually taller as well s5e has very
thin bezels a little strip of top little
strip at the bottom 16 by 10 aspect
ratio whereas the ipad has these really
large black bars this is gonna be an
even bigger deal if you're gonna watch a
Hollywood widescreen movie the black
bars are gonna be massive on the iPad
this screen is HDR capable YouTube is
not showing up as HDR so maybe YouTube
needs an update on an app to support
this new device the iPad does not
support HDR but another thing that I
noticed is as far as quality the iPad
only gives me 1080p even the display is
higher than 1080p
whereas s5e allows me to go up to 1440p
and max out kind of the resolution here
so I'm just gonna compare
1080p up first quality difference it's
kind of hard to tell even though we're
not in HDR the ultra whites are a bit
brighter and the as far as the blacks
they're a little bit more contrast II
but I'm very surprised by the colors
they're very close now I'm gonna go in
here and change it to 1440p and now I
could tell a difference definitely a lot
more detail in the Samsung so we have
brighter whites maybe a little bit more
saturation a little bit more contrast
and definitely a lot more detail
obviously if you're getting a better
quality video coming in it's making use
of that and giving you a more detailed
image now let's do a sound quality
comparison
[Music]
I am really really surprised obviously I
knew the sound is going to be more
immersive because we have four speakers
two on each side compared to just two at
the bottom of the iPad but having a more
immersive experience doesn't mean that
the sound quality is better or that it's
louder in this case all of that is true
it's more immersive we have twice a
speaker's stereo sound it's louder and
it sounds better it feels like the sound
is just hitting me in the face like I
said okay sorry I have to I have to
check out a movie here I have to check
out the sound it sounds good
I'm hearing a fact switch from the right
hand side to the left hand side yeah
that's good
alright so enough drooling over the
display and the speakers let's get to
what is the most important and that is
the CPU I'm cap joking but the CPU is
definitely really important along with
the graphics let's hit CPU let these
guys run and while that's going let me
tell you about the specs internally the
s5e has four gigs of ram compared to
three the ipad comes with a top-line
processor where this processor is kind
of like a mid-range phone processor and
along with that we're gonna have some
graphics difference as well I don't
really know what to expect on that end I
will be looking at some games but I
think I'll make that its own dedicated
video we can look at a few different
games so make sure you guys hit that
subscribe button enables notifications
if you guys want to see that video
the Samsung took way longer to complete
this and let's check out the scores over
here we have 1680 one single and 56 69
multi-core score with the iPad 48 24
compared to 11 502 so as far as the
actual performance there's no doubt
about it the iPad air has a top-line
processor now for the graphics you guys
have to see this this is scary I don't
want to see this score look how smooth
the iPad is perfectly smooth the test
results are in and the Samsung tablet
got totally destroyed as far as CPU the
iPad CPU is more than twice as powerful
for graphics three times as powerful
obviously the iPad is way better and
graphics are way ahead
cameras matter nowhere near as much in
tablet
as they do in smartphones but I still
want to do some comparisons as you guys
could see the iPad air has no camera
bump whereas the s5e definitely does
it's not horrible but it is there that
is because the s5e has a 13 megapixel
rear camera compared to 8 megapixel and
then on the front for selfies we have 7
megapixel compared to 8 so we have
better cameras on the Samsung I'm gonna
show you guys some photos here side by
side I'm gonna crop in you guys let me
know which one looks better from the
rear camera and then let's go ahead and
take some selfies you guys can tell me
which one looks better as well down in
the comments section below
now one interesting thing I noticed is
that we have live focus on the s5e let's
go ahead and take a photo which
direction let's say right over here of
course that I've had does not have that
the camera isn't as good and at the same
time we don't have any true depth
sensors or anything like that so that is
missing but you let me know what you
think about this photo down below now as
far as video we also have some
differences the s5 II can shoot 4k at 30
frames per second compared to just 1080p
at 30 on the iPad iPad can't even do
1080p at 60 frames per second so that is
a big difference as well let's do a
microphone and selfie video quality test
and you guys let me know which one is
better this is the audio quality test
from the Samsung Galaxy s5 II this is a
microphone quality test with the iPad
air 3 now there's one more difference
that I haven't yet mentioned and it's a
big one and that is the input devices
that you can use with these tablets with
the iPad air 3 you can buy an Apple
pencil and use it to draw write scribble
whatever you want to do you have that
capability and it's a great experience
not as good as iPad pro with the
promotion displays but it's still a very
good now with the new Samsung s5 II you
do not have that capability you can't
buy an S Pen and use it that's one area
where Samsung probably saves some money
but one area where the Samsung does
excel at is other input devices as you
guys can see right here I have a full
desktop experience you have the Dex
functionality previously you could plug
in your phone or your tablet
into a larger display switchover you
might need a doc now you could do that
in the tablet itself and as you guys you
can see here I have a web browser open I
have email open right over here I have
video open and so if you want to do some
work be more productive you can grab
your keyboard and air or any Bluetooth
keyboard really there you go
and with Android you can pair a mouse
and now I can literally be watching a
video working on some emails maybe doing
some research writing some notes what
the Android you have a full file browser
nothing is hidden or locked down I have
access to all these folders I can
organize however I want I can put in my
SD card from my camera I have access to
everything my video files plug in an
external flash drive or an SSD or
something like that and go and plug it
into a 27 inch display have a big
desktop like experience and get some
real work done but of course not
everybody's gonna need that or want to
use that or even care about it just like
with iPad not everybody's gonna care
about having this Apple pencil it really
is up to your use case and what you want
to do with these tablets do you let me
know down in the comment section below
which one of these would you prefer
which one would you buy and why I
definitely want to hear you guys it's
opinions like I mentioned we're gonna be
making more videos on the s5e so if you
want to see those click that little
circle above to subscribe if you guys
want to see a few more videos right now
I will have some right over here you
guys can click on that and check some of
those out there's been max with max tech
and I will see you in the next video